hello welcome to the newshour a u.n
court has rejected the appeal of the
former bosnian serb general radkomeladic
he was sentenced to life in 2017 for
genocide and war crimes including the
srebrenica massacre
well dubbed the butcher of bosnia mladic
was found guilty of his involvement in
the killing of more than 8
000 muslim men and boys during the
bosnian war in the 1990s
the judges upheld his conviction and
life sentence 26 years after the issue
of his
initial warrant in light of the gravity
of the offences committed by muhammad
and the noted spirited nature of the
benevolent president and the sisters
taken by him he does not demonstrate any
discernible error
in the chamber's assessment of
incentives
as a mitigated circumstance the general
sentencing practices
in the pharmaceutical in the former
yugoslavia
and fines judging the dissenting
that mr millard first demonstrated that
they tried to
aid in imposing a life sentence
we'll cross over to the hague and speak
to step fast and steph what is the
reaction to this
very mixed feelings here in the hague i
have to say
not only was the appeal by the defense
lawyers of mlaric
rejected but also by the prosecution so
uh relatives of victims who are
gathering here
at the u.n court say that there's a very
much
disappointment that not only the
genocide and sobrenica has been
recognized
but the genocide and other parts of
bosnia have been
rejected hasn't been called a genocide
and they say that's not fair
there have been lots of people who died
during that
part of the war as well which was before
the 1995
uh sabrinica massacre and they say it
would have been much more
uh giving a feeling of justice to the
victims in bosnia
if both uh parts were given the the
genocide uh a wording so that's why they
are very
disappointed about that on the other
side they were quite relieved of course
that the life sentence has been
upheld there was some concern that that
would also not be the case but they
are relieved about that they say this is
a momentous ending to a momentous trial
and one of the
uh spokespeople of the court came out
and he called it a milestone for
international justice
and at the same time he called on all
the member states especially in europe
to take care of the imprisonment of war
criminals
specifically mentioning maladic we asked
him
where will mladic be put to prison and
where will he serve the rest of his life
and he said he doesn't know
any hopes that some countries will step
forward like what they did with the
radovin
karachik who is now imprisoned uh he is
also a boston serbian leader he was also
sentenced to life he is now imprisoned
in the uk
so they're hoping that after sitting
here in the hague in the prison here
that he might be able to be moved
elsewhere
so for miladic is that it then step or
could further charges be brought against
him
now this seems to be really the final
final final day
in court because this has taken 10 years
it was a
very long trial with lots of people
coming in as testifying lots of
documents it's
it's called the the best documented
trial internationally it's seen as a
big success story 161 people were
indicted
many have been convicted it's seen as a
as an example for other international
cases that could be brought
to court so there was a lot at stake at
least for the international tribunals
with this verdict today but for miladic
this is the last chapter uh the curtain
has closed and he will be in prison for
the rest of his life
okay thank you so much davasan for that
reporting from the hague
let's speak to amir sulyage who's a
survivor of the srebrenica genocide he's
also the director
of the strabonita memorial center he's
joining us live thanks so much for
speaking to us
what's your reaction to the confirmation
of this life sentence
well to be completely honest i didn't
expect
much else um i was pleasantly surprised
that uh two out of five judges actually
voted
in favor of recognizing crimes committed
in other municipalities in bosnia
outside ceremony
as genocide i think that kind of changes
um the big picture uh quite a lot uh
it's now
a credible and legitimate school of
thought
uh legally speaking um other than that i
mean there was really no surprise uh
if you knew any if you know anything
about how the tribunal works if you know
about the amount of jurisprudence and
the amount of
actual physical evidence and testimony
that this trial has built upon um
you know you can be surprised so we are
where we are that's that that's that's
that's simply that's a that's a fact
that's it okay and as a survivor of the
genocide how important is this
final verdict for you
well i i don't know i think it's it's
it's a little too early to be honest i
mean you know
it's a little too early for me to be
introspective
to be to be completely honest i'm not
quite as
you know quite quite willing as yet to
sort of dig through through my feelings
but what i do know for a fact is
is that i'm gonna go home tomorrow and
i'm going to hug my baby girl
and that converge is never going to see
his grandkids again so
you know the big picture i think i kind
of feared better
you recently wrote this however you said
that when he mladic is gone forever his
life's work will still
be with us it will continue to poison
the future until it is reckoned with
oh yes yes so yeah so what what exactly
do you mean by that and
do you think people now are prepared to
come to terms with what happened
almost three decades after uh the war in
the genocide
now why do you say that
no of course not i mean and that's a
completely different matter
yeah well very simply because i actually
have um
i live in in this reality and in this
reality
you know we're in potter charter today
where most of the victims of seven
eights are buried
five away five kilometers away from here
is is a town where i was born it's
called bratwunats
and last night there was actually uh a
celebration
you know a gathering in celebration of
raccoons uh and it's done local you know
and
and there's an entire political class
that's heavily invested in
uh in ensuring that that komadich's
legacy
lives and and and there's a very simple
fact behind it uh
about 20 to 25 000 people were actually
involved in the celebrity operational
severance genocide operation alone
um about 200 000 people at
any one time during the the bosnian war
of uh
the bosnian war have actually been under
the command of our commodity so and
these are people who are actually
invested in him being a hero because
they actually have to look themselves in
the mirror every day
and and go on living knowing that
they've actually followed a mass
murderer
that they've committed rape that they've
committed murder that they've uh
taken part in forceful deportation
enforceable deportation so
you know that's why it's never it's not
i'm not i'm not an optimist when it
comes to that but hey
we're not about to enter a dialogue with
these people all right let me tell you
straight you know what we are telling
this narrative is based on facts it's
based on
forensic evidence it's based on dna
technology all right
what they're saying is based on on myth
on outright lie um and there cannot
really be a dialogue
you know we cannot really haggle about
the facts the facts of this matter have
been established
you can either accept them or you or
or or you cannot accept them that's
that's your choice but we're not going
to entertain we're not going to
entertain that
that's that's that's what i was saying
do you think this final ruling
will at least bring some closure to the
victims families
well i i don't know
i'm i i cannot speak for
mothers who have remained alone having
lost
their entire families you know their
livelihood
um for me
once again this is not something that
that this is something that i've
expected um
life goes on we will go on fighting
malaria's legacy in this country
we will ensure that or try to ensure
within our lifetime that
the injustice that he imposed on this
country is addressed one way or another
uh but we're not gonna you know he's
he's an afterthought
okay he's going to die somewhere
in in a in a crowded prison somewhere in
western europe you know
probably like cottage somewhere in uk
you know fearing
for his life every moment um
so you know i guess that kind of
balances it out but for me
you know i cannot speak on behalf of
anyone else
okay thank you so much amir sulyage for
speaking to us on al jazeera thank you
thank you